[Music]
now well as we've all heard the housing
market in las vegas is
red hot right now realtors say people
are moving here from all over the
country
making multiple offers raising demand
and prices
but what about the demand for luxury
homes bianca holman is live at one of
the most expensive properties in the
valley
to tell us about luxury demand and give
us a look inside we want to see
this house bianca
hey good morning sheri i'm inside the
movie room and all i have to say is
caviar dreams champagne wishes right
this is the lifestyle of the rich and
famous and i tell you
this home is 18 million dollars do you
have that in your back pocket well if
you do
this is the home for you and i'm joined
by the listing agent
amelia keane thank you so much for
waking up early for us but
to wake up early and be in this home
right it's so beautiful it's amazing and
thank you so much for being here so
early i know total respect for you guys
this home is truly uh the jewel of the
desert that's what we call it
and i'd like to introduce christy jesse
our kw luxury division chair
also with me this morning and my husband
but this home
truly is one of a kind and very stunning
and special it overlooks the entire las
vegas
and henderson valley i understand that
you know the the real estate market for
you know us normal folks is it's hard to
get a home but what about for that
luxury market you know are these homes
going fast
it is amazing that the luxury market in
las vegas used to be a small segment
now it's so hot you can't believe we
have very limited inventory
we have a lot of people as you know
moving here from different states
athletes celebrities we now have
professional football team and hockey
teams
so i think that's why people have
reevaluated their life
with covert over the last year and said
you know what i can live the life i
really want
move to las vegas and it used to be a
vacation destination and now it's a
place to live
and love yeah a place called home so if
people want to learn more we're going to
give you a sneak peek throughout the
show but if people want to learn more
about this jewel of the desert because
it truly is you can see the strip from
here you guys we're going to show you
when the sun rises
how can they learn more information well
the website is www
the jewel of the desert dot info and
we'd be happy to
let you see it and and take a wonderful
tour of the home yeah beautiful so i
can't wait to show you all the little
girls room the outdoors
the gym the spa they help a spa i don't
want to leave
i'll send it back to you guys in the
studio bianca is going to be there every
day
they're going to have to search for her
to make sure she's not hiding in a
closet
i think we just found our henderson
bureau
it's spectacular thank you bianca wow
so there's a game it's not that's more
than a movie room uh alex
oh my gosh there was a pinball in there
arcade
they had they had like snacks in the
counter candy bar
in there they have everything you know
there's a theater in there can you
just bring all the kids over go have at
it i think the
ball was just for the kids and there's a
different spa somewhere else in there
for the grown up at least wow but you
know
nate there's a point here not
necessarily just the luxury market but